we will proceed as we did in the morning
in alphabetical order so I'll just
introduce each of the panelists now and
then get going our first speaker will be
John bender who's professor of English
and comparative literature at Stanford
and former director of the Stanford
Humanities Center and author most
recently of the culture of diagram with
Mark O'Meara nan and ends of
enlightenment and then we will hear from
Sophie G is associate professor of
English at Princeton she's the author of
making waste and the scandal of the
season and is currently finishing a book
entitled infidelity the rise of the
sacrificial novel we will then hear from
Sarah Tyndall Karim who's associate
professor of English at UCLA her current
research focuses on how the metaphors
18th century writers used to talk about
reading fiction in particular the
metaphors of entering into a fictional
world or following a narrative thread
reflect and afford distinct modes of
read early attachment Wendy Lee is
assistant professor in the English
department NYU where she teaches 18th
century literature and philosophy she is
finishing a book that she says with
appropriate laconic quality about the
origins of the Bartleby problem and
finally last but not least Courtney Y
Smith is associate professor of English
at Wesleyan and her recent book
empiricist devotions science religion
and poetry in early eighteenth-century
England won the Cowan prize with no
further ado I had a title and I'll
explain it to you as we go along it's
fully effects in the gothic sound in the
castle vote righto and handouts going
around I'll wait don't start my 10
minutes yet Ruth
so a few modern critics have written
specifically about sound in the gothic
novel but very few but noises were
considered strong generic markers of the
Gothic in the 18th century itself three
different periodicals at the time and I
oh these references to Tasha Eccles
who's here
offer profiles of the Gothic and they
insist as say did the spirit of the
public journals in 1798 that the Gothic
required and I quote noises whispers and
groans and indeed demanded three score
at least of each and other profiles add
things like whistles wind rushes howls
rain creaking doors and clanking change
so the early inclusion of sound as a
marker of the Gothic works to confirm my
intuition that sounds are less prominent
in what we could call standard English
novels of the period than in the Gothic
and indeed for the 19th century the Lit
labs at Stanford has had a project which
seems to show that across the 19th
century novels become less loud and
noisy with the decline of words like
shriek cried screamed and other such
things conversely when I opened a tronto
to prepare this talk I was overwhelmed
by the perfusion of sonic dimensions in
the texts beginnings and thereafter
their eruptions have sound everywhere
and also marked silences now this
encounter brings me to Foley effects one
very prominent kind of sound effect in
film so what are fully effects like
virtually every sound in a film you
attend other than dialogue they're laid
down on a soundtrack after
the shooting of the film only dialog is
recorded generally they're superimposed
by the invisible hand of the Foley
artist I'm viewing Walpole here as an
unseen sound artist who calls attention
to crucial noises and Walpole sounds
like those in films are highly selective
and very very importantly louder than in
real life that those glasses clinking in
the lock latching the footsteps creaking
are there always louder there are
exceptions I mentioned those in a minute
so he simulates simulates a sense of
real sonic experience using the Unreal
device of printed words Michelle she all
says a film great great sound theorist
he says the realist art of cinema has
progressed only by straining against its
own principle through forceful doses of
unrealism and I would say that of Trento
fits this as well the point being that
what we perceive as realism in film is
actually very stylized indeed it's a
series of simulations now Foley sounds
are made with real objects but
disconnected from the real there are
simulations Foley effects and other
sound effects they achieve realism but
often by employing the not real famous
instance in the literature on sound in
film is snow real snow does not sound
like snow you have to use cornstarch and
real silk Stalkings don't sound like
silk stockings you have to use nylon and
there countless other examples I'll
mention some of them along the way the
great sound engineer Walter Murch made
this observation and it's been picked up
widely in the film criticism so this
kind of realism like I would say
realism in a novel in general does not
equal the real so Foley effects almost
always imply the spectral therefore
because they come out of nowhere she no
again has this term the audiovisual
contract and I think that's very much at
work in Otranto the idea is that when we
see a film if we just saw the image but
we just heard the soundtrack it would be
ineffective there's an audio-visual
contract in which we witness them
together and they have this magical
realistic generally realistic character
so there's a synergistic Co presence of
image and sound so what are the traits
of Foley effects their actual sounds on
soundtracks like locks boards
floorboards clinking glasses folding
sheet metal so sometimes their actual
sounds of things that may appear in the
film they're almost always louder than
they would be in real life now silence
in real life never is truly silent you
hear that in the background here so if
you were making a film of this room
your Foley artist would record that
sound and lay it on the track as the
sound of this room
Foley puts all of those kinds of sounds
on film Street noise the noises of a
hotel doors closing people talking TV's
on and so forth but still the
differentiation between silence and
sound effects is very important in film
and a very famous example is this
extremely short total silence in
Godfather 2 at the end when Michael is
sitting by the lake having had his
brother murdered and the sound slowly
goes down to absolute silence novels can
give us absolute silence and Otranto
does that and this may be the moment to
mention Rob
Hasan's assertion that with sound coming
into film silence in film became
possible now silent films weren't really
silent I mean there was orchestras and
all sorts of things but but you you
can't have one without the other you
can't have sound effects silence without
sound effects now sound effects in film
in general are aimed at the audience but
there are exceptions in sound effects
that render psycho effects of a
character very common in horror films
and we see that I'll show you in a
minute
you know Toronto with Isabella down in
the subterranean corridor so having told
you something about Foley I'm going to
show you the making of Foley for a short
film sequence police chase on your left
will be the film and on the right will
be the Foley artists and notice that
sometimes they're doing what's happening
and sometimes they're doing something
completely different it just has to be
two minutes
you're on Michelle
vote me into the promise of granting
sound effects live in the studio along
to a pre-recorded piece of video Foley
artist this is a variety of crops to a
third place sounds that could not
properly be captured on set
here you see two Oliver Foley artists
three an action sequence delay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I think we just op there you're missing
the part where the cup where the thief
punches the cup and this is an example
of an of a different sound creating the
real because what the Foley artist punch
is the leg of lamb real punches don't
make that sound apparently and so you
have to punch something else to make the
sound so what we have here sometimes is
they're doing what the character in the
films are doing other times they're
making some kind of artful substitute
and so they're producing a real-life
realism by a high artificiality that
substitutes alternatives very often for
normal sounds that we would hear now
let's look quickly at the handout I'll
just point out a couple of things
they're more highlighted things that I
can cover I believe but the first is the
famous rustling sound of the
proportionable quantity of plumes on the
fatal helmet this seems to me a perfect
example of the audio-visual contract you
have the plumes moving okay without the
rustling sound without that Foley effect
it would not be the vivid thing that it
is and then the picture sighing in some
gothic novels pictures sigh and then
step out of the frame which would be
even better
and then once here the second part the
lower part of the castle sure you're all
familiar with this flight of Isabel into
the lower chambers of the castle and
there's an awful silence there now
that's a total novelistic silence that's
not the silence of this room or or a
foley silence and the novel can give
that to us but then blasts of wind shake
the doors as she passed rusty hinges
creak there re-echoed down the labyrinth
so you can imagine how these Foley
artists would would create that echo
but then something happens every murmur
struck her with new terror and the
sounds move inside into phantasms and in
imaginations of her head and a film
those would still be rendered you know
but but we would into it through the
audiovisual contract that we were now
fusing the sounds with her mind rather
than with some external object like a
door hinge then we get the gust of wind
the lamp total darkness you I think turn
over this is where Theodore appears and
the moonshine Jonathan mentioned earlier
coming down and striking the trapdoor
that they're looking for she touches it
the spring clicks goes down in total
darkness now total darkness is also very
hard to achieve in the real world but
you can have it in the novel it's very
hard to achieve on film actually because
then the image goes away and we just
have a blank screen so then she goes
down through the trapdoor and I'll just
close the discussion of the handout with
this shut the trap door after you
she says she left the door slip out he
left the door slip out of his hands it
fell and the spring closed over it the
noise and now becomes died genic again
the noise of the falling door had been
heard by Manfred so now we take off and
Manfred cries out okay so this is
basically my intuition that there's a
kind of special sound in Otranto that is
produces realism through the unreal and
I just note a few other places in the
gothic novel where I think we could
discuss this if we weren't doing the
conference equivalent of speed-dating
various sequences in Rudolfo were
Valon Cory's playing the lute etosha
gave me that one the odd lack of sound
at the end of the monk when I was
working on this I thought oh the end of
the monk will be very noisy but it's not
very interesting throne voices in
violent and confessions of a justified
sinner Rochester's mysterious cried to
Jane in Jane Eyre the wind in weathering
Heights and lots and lots of sounds in
Edgar Allan Poe so it's just a kind of
informal intuition about the novel I had
a lot of fun reading these great film
theorists I have one of Michele she owns
books here and Walter Murch is only on
the web but he's absolutely fantastic he
did the sound for the Godfather films
and and many other truly memorable films
so that's it John you've got me thinking
about a lot of different things but
including what would be the speed-dating
version of a conference it maybe
marriage yeah yeah okay so I'm - I want
to talk with my ten minutes about
Authority about inwardness and about how
the two states coexist with some passing
references sort of a Toronto and I'm
going to present this as a list with
some detailed points and I mean I'm into
lists at the moment because they don't
require an argument so you can you can
do what you like with them okay so point
one so this is a very odd book which
relapses from time to time into other
kinds of oddity the sort of quite
unquote realistic spaces that we would
associate with 18th century
places like the nursery the boarding
school the men's club I think that these
sites are sort of kicking around
unacknowledged in the Castle of Otranto
in these moments where the dialogue
really could go in either direction it
could belong in a realist novel or it
could be what you should belong in a
realist novel but instead it's in a
gothic novel and I'll and I've chosen
those sites advisedly so I'll tell you
why in a minute what we see in Toronto
is that that no space is beyond the
reach of authority and the and the fact
that there's this constant crossover
between the Gothic and the real in a
Toronto invites us to notice how both
modes involve acts of what I'm calling
overreaching Authority so where some
kind of coercion
involves a kind of infiltration into
minds into bedrooms into bodies these
things take place in in in novels of all
kinds
despite the ways in which novels stake
out a very strong spatial discipline or
boundary creation for themselves we've
talked about doors and things but you
know just the big spaces of novels
country houses the picaresque mode the
castle the grotto the vault these are
all places where we might think that
I've already might be able to be
contained rather than continue to
overreach but novels are places where
everything can reach into everything
else
often ludicrously and really the only
place I can think of in a Toronto where
overreaching or reaching is not as
successful it's not achieved is when
Theodore can't reopen the trapdoor and
reach into the tunnel or whatever it is
so that's point one point two is that
there is a group of contemporary
thinkers like
people now who are interested in
revisiting the status of faith and
belief as a post-christian on new
humanist form of understanding these
people are trying to think about the
validity of convictions of a certain
type of conviction that is obligatory
involuntary and which is oriented toward
idealization and abstraction rather than
toward empiricism or materiality so the
key terms here are a type of
understanding that is conferred upon the
individual as an obligation and which
reaches toward an idealization or an
abstraction takes us out of the
empirical so these thinkers are arguing
for renewed attention actually to a form
of overreaching the reaching of
obligation into places that have
scrupulously been freed from the
politics of obligation like minds and
feelings this is supposed to be what
happens in the eighth century terms that
doesn't work people are revisiting this
question that's prevailing in a certain
strain of modern contemporary philosophy
is whether it's possible to perform an
action or hold a position without choice
but still be free so in other words
there is a return to pre secular ideas
about belief and behavior about the idea
that beliefs and behaviors can be made
obligatory which in the early modern
period would have been constructed by
inflexible among other things by
inflexible religious forms forms of
belief and this type of obligation has
been called obedience and obedience is
is pretty out of fashion so the
theoretical move among this group of
post-christian new humanist scholars is
to reconstitute obedience but to lose
the belief and behavior part of it
so to think of a
a form of obligation that is might be
freeing because it doesn't produce
prescriptions around belief or action so
it's quite subtle really so the
religious anthropologist ll Assad has
summarized what I've just said as the
notion that formality is necessarily an
external form of coercion is
questionable in other words he's asking
whether it's possible to enter a system
of meaning without choice and yet not be
unacceptably constrained by it okay so
my third point which you know as
advertised is not precisely related to
one or two is that we think of the 18th
century as the moment in which critique
emerges as a way of thinking so quick
revision of what critique is it's an
attempt to problematize or trouble
obligation specifically the kind of
obligation that is involved in the
production of facts and other fixed or
immovable truths so facts command
acquiescence not only to what they in
for myself but of how they do the
informing we have to submit to that and
critique reinstalls a care for personal
interior 'ti and inwardness in an effort
to override the rise of the modern state
I get that that's it
SuperDuper summary but let's just go
with it for now critique sort of has a
preference for what in a different
political moment we might call the soft
truth and what I mean by that is
knowledge that must be produced
counter-intuitively
that depends upon logic that infiltrates
the box or the trapdoor of a fact and
reveals it to be a kind of fiction and
you know a few years ago bruno latour
got very worried about that
and gave a critique of critique in which
he said that it was time to or maybe it
was time to restore real facts and to
defend them against the charge that they
are fake facts or liberal conspiracies
in other words that the left was now
being obligated to do what it had
previously had to move so decisively
away from namely to restore the fact as
it as a as a primary epistemological
unit okay so that's um that's three
point for the Walpole that I work with
is the wrong Walpole I work with the
unfashionable one Robert who obviously
was Horace's father and it's interesting
to me that Horace is the third son that
seems relevant somehow anyway
Walpole Roberts Walpole's administration
again this is a massive summary but it
really was invested in in facts and it
was invested in the fictional machinery
of statehood that was required to
generate facts Walpole and the wings of
the earlier eighteenth century were
their commitment to Liberty produced a
model of statehood in which
participation became entirely
involuntary so one of the chief
spokespeople for Robert Walpole's model
of statehood a kind of hygienic very
efficient secular state that was
separate from the church but had a
national church was a guy called
Benjamin Hoadley who some people might
have heard of some people won't have he
delivered a very contentious sermon at a
particular moment during Walpole's
actually was before Walpole became prime
minister it was in 1717
but he continued on into whirlpools
period and became his sort of
propagandist anyway hardly said that an
act of parliament should not reach to
the inward disposition and he used this
claim as the basis for designing a kind
of contemporary theology that pushed
belief pushed religion pushed
abstraction and idealization to the
margins of the social world and in
stated what we think of as the modern
state and what I want to do really
quickly is read a passage from the
sermon that hardly gave in which he laid
this out and what I want you to notice
about the passage is the is it's gothic
elaboration it's extremely overwrought
it relies on a kind of theological
hysteria though without sound effect and
what I want us to think about here is
this idea that the production of an
ongoing state of a state of material
realities contaminated by their
overreaching into other closed systems
that the production of that also
produces a kind of gothic register so
here's the passage if any man upon earth
have a right to add to the sanction of
his laws that is to increase the number
or alter the nature of the rewards and
punishments of his subjects in matters
of conscience or salvation they are so
far Kings in his stead and rein in their
own Kingdom him here been Christ and not
in his so it is whenever they erect
tribunals and exercise the judgment over
the consciences of men and assume
themselves to the determination of such
points as cannot be determined but by
one who knows the hearts or when they
make any of their own declarations or
decisions to concern and affect the
state of Christ subjects with regard to
the favor of God this is so far the
taking of Christ's Kingdom out of his
hands and placing it into their own so I
going to end by reflecting that it took
an enormous amount rhetorically speaking
cognitively
and in terms of it well it took a lot it
took a lot to segregate conscience and
action to separate the world of the fact
from the world of the idealization or
abstraction and a lot of that work was
done during Walpole's period in office
and that i think that a Tron toe is is
is is considering some of the
implications of that that that
segregation yeah
[Applause]
all right I'm really happy to be here I
wanted to thank Jonathan and Nicole and
everyone else for being here
really enjoyed hearing all the panelists
and seeing lots of connections between
observations we'd be making what I'm
going to be talking about today relates
in a roundabout kind of way to the book
projects I'm working on in the moment
and I wanted to begin by situating a
little bit and explaining that the
second book project in its current
iteration emerged from a crisis I had
about two or three months ago where I
was just sort of pathologically
procrastinating and did not found that I
did not want to write the book that I
had designed for myself to write which
was it was titled suspended world and it
was meant to be about these kinds of
metaphors of delicate enclosures like
bubbles and other types of spaces and
thinking about how those worked as
metaphors for fiction in the period but
I'd become really just fascinated by
Hogarth's account of intricacy and the
mouths of beauty and I kept telling
everybody I just want to write about
intricacy I just want to shelf that
whole thing and then and this is a very
very kind of la epiphany story I was
driving along Sunset Boulevard and if
you've ever driven along Sunset it's an
extremely winding road full of these
sort of hairpin bends and I suddenly
decided that no this was a book about
two different figures and so I retitled
they're actually pulled off sunset to
write this down and I decided was gonna
be called the thread and the shell forms
of attachment in 18th century literature
and that it was going to be about these
two paradigms or Gestalt s-- for the way
in which people read as in the 18th
century are being invited to read one
with which is a model of pursuits and
following a thread and the other one is
of entering this kind of delicate
enclosure and that's the shell so
in the course of becoming of bringing
these two ideas together I've become
really fascinated with dadless for
reasons partly to do with the nature of
his inventions and his interest in both
threads and shells so if this paper had
a title it would be called dead alien or
Toronto except that I don't really know
how to pronounce the word deadly and
daylian so I I won't call it that but
that's what it would be if it had a
title okay so the adjective dead alien
which I only discovered maybe month a
month ago means are in the style of
Daedalus skillful ingenious formed with
art resembling the labyrinth of Daedalus
that he he designed a creep that house
the Minotaur intricate and maze like so
specifically my interest in it is are
the kind of synonyms or the intricate
but it's also and this picks up on on
Sophie what Sophie was talking about
it's a term that Bruno two years uses
and turns into a noun so for Latour
added alien is a technical mediation
that creates detours and and I think
it's actually also kind of connects to
what you were saying about where the
question of whether something can be
constraining or whether you but you can
also be free at the same time so added
alien constrains behavior but not in a
way that's deterministic but the rather
sort of pushes you in certain directions
and his main example is in Pandora's
hope his main example of a dead alien as
a speed bump but in that same the same
chapter where he discusses the dead
alien the speed bump Saturday Leah and
he also says that fiction is a dead
alien fictions are also detours that we
can make as he says without leaving our
seats so with this concept in mind I
decided that Walpole strikes me as a as
a dead alien writer someone who like
Daedalus himself most famously in his
labyrinth shapes matter in a way that
creates detours will poles letters and
I'm going to be
fighting bits of tax that have already
come up fascinatingly today all poles
letters refer to both reading and
writing as a matter of imaginatively
moving bodies in space moving or
stilling I should say bodies in space so
when he's contemplating adding a bow to
Strawberry Hill he wonders if he and
this is a quotation must go and read
Spencer and wade through his allegories
and drooling stanzas to get at a picture
and quote and we we kind of had this
sense in that moment that he really
wants a snapshot he wants a picture of
of romance of a bower he doesn't want a
peregrination or to have to pursue
something but Spencer demands pursuit
and and kind of reading as a detour then
on other occasions the the activity of
spooling out narrative just lurches to a
stop very suddenly when he's writing a
Toronto he recalls and this is the part
of the passage of that cindy quoted
earlier I was so engrossed with my tale
that one evening I wrote from the time I
drunk my tea at about six o'clock till
half an hour after 1:00 in the morning
when my hand and fingers were so weary
that I could not hold the pen to finish
the sentence but left Matilda and
Isabella talking in the middle of a
paragraph so there I think or in we have
both of those situations in mind the the
wading through Spencer together the
picture and the kind of writing in a
kind of rush and then leaving Matilda
and Isabella Isabella marooned mid
paragraph I think Walpole shaped space
in such a way as to produce these kinds
of situations in a Toronto in the novel
itself he shaved space and in such a way
that enclosures turn into passages and
passages turn into enclosures in which
tableaus move and moving bodies stopped
in their tracks and I think in staging
these ships between stillness and motion
he's reflecting on the relationship
between two modes of representation and
this is where I'm getting to the kind of
thread and shell idea that in which a
frame encloses content and that in which
content unfolds progressively in a way
that needs to be pursued or followed so
the famous moment in which the portrait
of Manfred's grandfather quits its panel
is only the most striking of several
instances in which a frame becomes a
threshold and this is itself as I've
discovered recently through reading
endlessly about Daedalus a kind of
deadly and spectacle so did alien I
should just decide how to pronounce that
word the daily whose sculpture is
sculpture that is supposedly so lifelike
that the Daedalus was said to produce
statues that walked or that moved and
and Aristophanes has a lost play that
supposedly turns on a statue of Daedalus
is that just that that walks on that
walks that moves the moment in which the
portrait quits its panel for shadows one
that follows in quick succession and
other one that's been alluded to several
times today in which theodor supposed to
be confined under the faithful helmet
escapes from the helmet on into the
vault below when Manfred finds him he
discovers and this is a another
quotation that one of the cheeks of the
enchanted cask had forced its way
through the pavement of the court as his
servants had let it fall over the
peasant and had broken through into the
vault leaving a gap through which the
peasant had pressed himself and I'm
going to come back a little bit that
language just in a minute but just to
say in a Toronto every time Providence
opens a gap in the roof it also slams
shut a trap door Isabelle urges Theodore
to shut the trap door after he exits but
as we've just heard it slams shut up
before he has the chance thereby as John
was saying signalling his presence to
Manfred what noise was that said Manfred
wish I heard as I entered the cloister a
door collapse of the peasant I heard
as well as you moments like these turn
passages into enclosures and enclosures
into passages in ways and I guess this
is my gambit or claim here that seem to
assert the agency of the frame itself it
is the helmet not Theodore that forces
its way through the floor in in that
passage I read before with the cheeks
breaking down into the floor below it's
the door that claps not Theodore who
shuts it and I wonder if we might see
these moments and this is speculative as
ones in which the border exerts its own
agency as textual incarnations of the
arabesque
that that movement in which decorative
and ornamental forms associated with
borders and frames that that movement
associated with those kinds of frames
and also often comprising of leaf work
and shall work so then my final this is
my final point but I'm gonna try to
extemporize a little bit in explaining
what I mean I think that Otranto is
merging a frame and in framed passage
and enclosure draws our attention then
to these two different metaphors I want
to suggest by which we understand
representations on the one hand it's a
pursuit Manfred and this is another
quotation is impatient to unravel this
clue and again it's a something I didn't
know until recently but that probably
many of you know that the word clue
comes from the ball of thread that you
use to to navigate a labyrinth and so
the hole is something that quite
literally there the idea of unraveling a
clue but at the same time and I think
Gina was talking about this
he's also transfixed by the helmet and
that's like another model of kind of
suspense and and being transfixed and
you know I think likewise in the way
novel Toronto works as a novel you know
it's clearly and we'll pull alludes to
this and this
it's trying to kind of produce this kind
of suspense and tension in the reader
that we might associate more with this
pursuit model but it's also and I think
it was against Cindy who reminded me of
this you know he characterizes the the
way he comes up with the novel as
deriving from or he says that his head
is filled with a gothic story that it's
like that we're kind of traveling into
that space of the head filled with
gothic story in a way that sort of
suggests more of a sort of static image
that we can enter a kind of living
picture so I think then I think that
there's a way in which the novel is
drawing our attention to what we might
call kind of she'll work on the one hand
and thread work and the other and the
ways in which these these are two
paradigms but in a way that's really I
don't know exactly how to describe it
but just like vexing and and I'll just
end by saying the the word unravel is
I've become completely obsessed with the
word unravel an unraveled mystery is
both a solved mystery and an unsolved
one because the word unravel means both
the opposite of the verb Ravel and the
opposite and and and unravel yeah I'm
gonna get it wrong it's just like makes
my head hurt so much to think about it
but in essentially essence it's a solved
mystery and an unsolved mystery and I
think that what Walpole was doing here
is something like sort of confronting us
with the limits of these different modes
hermeneutic modes or modes of
interpretation and kind of like just
like letting us but up against them and
making out bring her by having them
constantly kind of shift shift modes and
shift into another just all the time and
and constantly so I will leave it there
thank you
okay thank you
Thank You Jonathan Thank You Nicole and
Yael and I feel like this standard here
for me is the substitute teacher because
I'm a fill in for Michael gamer
okay so just bear that bear that in mind
so I don't write about a Walpole or a
Toronto and I'll just do the best I can
and I was saying to Gina
I feel like this is the the gay version
of her talk so keep that in mind okay so
rereading the Castle of Otranto I felt
like like most texts this is one that is
probably best experienced as a drag show
and I mean like all Queens kind of drag
show and I'm talking about something
that I guess for Walpole Ian's is so
obvious that you don't maybe didn't want
to talk about it today which is camp
that sort of a special Walpole Ian
sensibility and I thought for this group
including Sara but I think also Sean and
Jessi and others we could apply camp as
a test for the experience of wonder and
so my question would be whether camp and
can't be pleasure is antithetical to
wonder whether camp is to knowing to
surface to made now I think sarah has
already provided an answer to this in
her book which is to say no it's not
antithetical in novels you won she makes
this gorgeous distinction to wonder at
and to wonder about an object so in
novel reading you have this double
experience of recognition and
estrangement enchantment and
disenchantment suspense and admiration
what she beautifully calls the very
similar marvelous so here's an example
of that I think in the Castle of Otranto
read by Joseph Roach take it away Joe
oh okay in this scene also sorry okay
looks like to you up so of course um
Theodore you know his shirt cuz he's
about to be you know like beheaded
versus or whatever by Manfred and his
you know it's kind of like in a tennis
match when Rafael Nadal's is is playing
and after the match he changes his
sweaty shirt and like the whole audience
gasps at his like abdominals so it's
that kind of moment he's his shirt falls
and reveal and reveals a shoulder it
reveals the bloody arrow
take it away professor Roach what do I
see is it my child my Theodore the
passions that ensued must be conceived
they cannot be painted the fears of the
assistants were suspended by wonder
rather than stopped by joy they seemed
to inquire the eyes of their Lord what
they ought to feel surprised out
tenderness respect succeeded each other
in the countenance of the youth he
received with modest submission the
effusion of the old man's tears and
embraces get afraid of giving a ruse to
hope and suspecting
from what he had passed what had passed
the inflexibility of man offense temper
he cast a glance towards the prince as
if to say hence now be unmoved at such a
scene
[Applause]
okay so you see the two experiences
there first that you know that
suspension of wonder so itself is a kind
of suspension of feeling and then the
the you know servants have to say okay
what am I supposed to feel here am I
supposed to feel you know they're
looking to see what we're to what to
slot into that emptiness and then that
great moment where Theodore's like are
you taking this in are you seeing like
you know how moving this is okay so to
go back to camp so in the Sonntag essay
there are a few definitions of camp camp
is a logic of taste it's a way of
looking its self-parody plus self love
it's a tender feeling and here's Joseph
Roach last year or a year before at a
sex on horace walpole on camp
so in roaches statement if kitsch in
Milan Kundera's formulation is the
complete absence of [ __ ] think
Cinderella's castle at Magic Mountain
then camp by contrast means kitsch with
all the [ __ ] self-consciously and
artfully restored okay so number 56 in
some tags si camp taste is a kind of
love love for human nature in other
words it doesn't judge so is the Castle
of Otranto is the novel a vehicle to
accommodate and exonerate male feeling
especially as and josa reading flushes
this out especially the primary
ambivalence towards women in other words
the Harvey Weinstein's story every time
that is to say men's constitutional
incapacity to regulate their passions
and women's collective endurance of
their
edible victimization roach rights that
camp isn't about escape but relief that
it isn't transgression but expansion and
here are some great formulations that
camp is an earnest in sincerity that
it's an exclamation point disguised by a
question mark camp reveals no hidden
depths he writes because what is hiding
in plain sight needs all the therapeutic
recuperation it can get so rereading it
now in this moment I thought well what
camp knows is that the story of
heterosexuality is a really sad one and
as Sandra McPherson in person and in her
scrupulous scholarship reminds me it's a
story in which men are confused and
women get hurt or destroyed all the time
camp allows us to see that story for
everything it's worth you get to feel
sorry for it the whole catastrophe we're
tending towards in Walpole's language
good to feel sorry for it feel sorry for
ourselves our loved ones and our enemies
but also like we get it here's roach
again camp stages what is too important
to be taken seriously and I would adjust
to what is to true to be taken seriously
here's where I think that camp may be in
compatible with wonder and I rely here
on Spinoza's description of wonder which
is when you behold an object that for
you has no precedence in quality or
degree and so it absorbs all of your
attention because you have no chain of
associations that it launches no field
of reference in beholding that object
and this is Spinoza
wonder is the conception of anything
we're in the mind comes to a stand
because the particular concept in
question has no connection with other
concepts in Otranto and in camp we see
the aggressively unavoidable precedents
of the story its dogged tragic and
hilarious persistence so Harvey
Weinstein or Hamlet or Henry the eighth
but also thank God the saucy Harold the
unhappy princesses the unknown mutes the
handsome Cavalier the buried and mangled
and bleeding and disfigured and - two
pieces already puny on athletic body of
Conrad my hunch is that camp is a way to
avoid contempt this is for Spinoza the
opposite feeling of wonder contempt is
the conception of anything which touches
the mind so little that its presence
leads the mind to imagine those
qualities which are not in it rather
than such as are in it an example of
contempt here like I last week I went to
a very straight very white millennial
wedding and it's you know it's so
destroying experience like you think are
they real is he really gonna kiss the
bride are they really gonna feed each
other cake is they're really gonna be a
first dance and they do they do all of
it and and and it would be horrible
except that you know a few days before I
had gone at NYU to the Halloween drag
queen Cinderella
big extravagant performance and there's
some way in which drag redeems the
rituals of heterosexuality so you get to
in tamp you get to eat the cake you're
stuck with no matter that it's made of
[ __ ] and guaranteed to make you sick and
will probably kill you but here's a
better version of that metaphor you
don't have to ingest the cake yourself
you do get to cheer on all the Queens
while they're eating it and not just
eating it but ripping off each other's
tiaras over it
stuffing it in each other's bra cups and
drop and jock straps wrapping the goopy
pieces of it in glittered wax paper ant
insulated ribbon and then firing all of
those packages out of a unicorn rainbow
to shooting cannon so that it pours over
the whole Fiesta like confetti at a
Donna Summer concert that was the gay
version of Gina's thanks Jonathan Nicole
for today such fun
I too am going to talk about the sounds
of Otranto so as John beautifully showed
us there's lots to say about the novel's
inarticulate sounds which anticipate a
now-familiar gothic soundscape of the
disembodied indefinite eerie for example
a passage John cited an awful silence
reigned throughout those subterranean
regions except now and then some blasts
of wind that shook the door Isabella had
passed and which grading on the rusting
hinges were Rijeka through that long
labyrinth of darkness every murmurs
struck her with a new terror
Isabella van El Fran's book gothic music
the sounds of the uncanny sites this
passage as it summarized the gothic
conventions that Otranto helped shape
quote the advent of terror is generally
preceded by an unworldly sided silence
aided by meteorological wind Thunder
rain or technical rattling fences
hissing pipes circumstances and
announced by sounds that suggest
presence creaks echoes voices music
indeed van elver entreats echo as the
perfect figure for what she calls the in
flash materiality of gothic sound an
echo quote suggests physical presence
but it is disconnected from it like a
phantom doppelganger of its former self
and my new project is an intellectual
history of the sound of words and a
poetic sound in particular so I want to
talk today in a rather speculative way
about the novel's articulate sounds the
way the sounds linked with semantics
if Walpole's re-echoing participates in
a gothic tradition of disembodied sounds
that tantalizingly suggests but refused
to confirm some other presents his
various ways of highlighting articulate
sounds might suggest a different
understanding as themselves present and
embodied fascinating work by actually
many people in this room has underscored
the importance of the novels things I'm
asking if the novel sketches to the
possibility that words are a kind of
thing so approached as many 18th century
writers approach them echoes are a
useful figure for this understanding - I
have to admit that I've been thinking
way too much recently about popes the
sound must seem an echo to the sense and
then echoes in particular
Walpole did some thinking about echoes
to post on Toronto he wrote a silly
one-act performance piece featuring the
early modern tradition of echoes verse
in this tradition words are compounded
material things moving through space and
time words bounce around disaggregate
and their parts change meaning so in a
traditional echo verse a speaker asks
tell me what is that supreme delight and
the echo answers light so delight light
it comes apart in Walpole's version a
hilarious version actually a Fairy
punishes a man with the loss of some
part of himself
but he gets to choose which part he must
communicate his choice to echo the man
chooses an expendable part his tears but
the echo catches only ears
I did not say my ears the man insists
but the echo hears only confirmation
ears desperate the man tries to break
the word into parts my te AR s but of
course the echo catches only e a RS like
other echo verse Walpole's judas
pre-treat sounds as the building blocks
of sense in a resolutely material way
combining recombining drifting moving
echoing sounds need not be thought of as
immaterial phantom doppelgangers of lost
presence they are themselves present
nuggets of meaning moving through space
and time wall poles novel seems
literally to begin like something like
the
something like the echo versus
aggregation of EA rs4 the title page
gives the real Italian writers names as
a new free Omer Alto s Sir Walter Scott
has suggested this name is a sort of
anagram of Horatio Walpole four letters
are missing and some new ones are added
Scott also caused that a kind of
translation and after him some fantastic
theories have been floated wall goes
French mu R a pole can be alto Italian
for high and so on letters and sounds
pull apart drift recombine they signify
an obscure Otranto features other sound
play in the spirit of echo versus well
when Matilda faints after overhearing
matil Manfred sentence Theodore to death
Bianca shrieks help help the princess is
dead Bianca's words moves manfred hears
them and stops what he is doing to
figure out what happened we later find
out that the words traveled yet further
and as they move their meaning shifted a
monk visiting the castle heard the
scream and then brought word to the
convent that another princess Hippolyta
was dead sounds our wayward things they
carry meaning but not always reliably if
hear the sounds retain their proper
shapes as words unlike tears ears
Walpole also allowed sound shapes to
morph in their movements thus his comic
malapropism when the servant jacquees
who Manfred calls a blockhead is
reporting the supernatural sight his
friend saw while they were supposed to
be looking for Isabella he says quote we
were comprehensive we might meet a ghost
he means apprehensive and there's a
playful irony in the fact that because
they were apprehensive they were totally
failing to be comprehensive in their
search the idea I think is that Jacquizz
has heard apprehensive before he held on
to the word and now tries to work with
it but he isn't in control of the sound
in the sense both there's an extra
materially charged irony here in that
there is an etymological link to that
between the two words the Latin Prien
dura to grasp which is exactly what
jacquees feels at doing words move and
their physical parts and meanings can
shift in the traveling grasping and
reusing of course like echo verse and
anagram both the overheard phrase and
the clownish malapropism have long
literary histories but the fact
the conventions are borrowed don't
undercut doesn't undercut the way of
thinking sound that they offer if the
sounds of words our wayward materials
the punning on pre Honduras suggests
that they are also historical materials
Walpole often uses obsolete or archaic
forms of English words the Broadview
Edition Flags Disco pate Halliday Moana
and course for corpse as well as a whole
host of terms describing armour and
architecture such terms like the
historical objects that some of them
reference persists from the past and
especially with the archaic spellings
it's particularly their corporeal shape
as words that persist there are other
ways to that the novel's words get
aligned with its historical things
Theodore's body is marked just nicely
reminded us his facial features have an
exact resemblance to his ancestor
alfonso and his back bears the mark of
the bloody arrow but his name too is a
thing that contains this speak secret as
scholars have noted Theodore comes from
the Greek words Theo's Endora
it means God given my name is Theodore
he says climactically just before his
father recognizes him and in the end
Theodore is both good rightful heir to a
truant row given Oh Tonto by
supernatural forces of course the
etymological secret is made the more
complicated by the editors proposal that
the names of the novel are fictitious
probably disguised on purpose but
whether we think the name comes from
Jerome and his wife or from an artful
medieval writer or from Walpole himself
Theodore is the product of a prior act
of naming that Marx is prior right to
Atrato
certainly we can't put this pressure on
all of the names but in all of his fond
play including the eerie echoes that
interests vent Alfred her her account of
Gothic sound Walpole throws out
possibilities without fully developing
them in some intriguing ways Halliday
wonõt Theodore wall pulls words are like
echoes sounds that move meaningfully if
unpredictably through space and time
since I've been working here alongside
but against the grain of L van L friends
account
I'll close as she does she notes that
for all its talk of sounds the page of
the gothic novel is itself mute grace
Poole's laughter in Jane Eyre is all the
more frightening because it is doubly
removed from its
alleged origin first through its ghostly
disembodiment and second because the
reader does not actually hear it for Van
Alfred the mute page makes gothic sounds
doubly immaterial and uncanny this is
not I think how Walpole's various plays
with the sounds of words work if
anything repeated phrases malapropisms
and etymologies heighten our sense of
the physical qualities of words in our
ears and on the page the sound plays us
seem related to other found texts in the
novel the couplet written on the unearth
saber blade the ancient prophecy
difficult to make any sense of which is
said to have pronounced that word
interests me the downfall of the present
family and of course Walpole first
presented his novel itself as a found
object like the sounds it features the
novel itself is a material historical
wayward thing this brings me to a final
question or puzzle I've long been struck
by the way the sound of the novel
changes at the end Sorella alliterative
pairs in pious intentions reason to
rejoice they're everywhere but then
Manfred stabs Matilda and suddenly we
get these intense patches of
alliteration that feel to me like a
departure from the earlier approach
you'll just have to listen here
murderous monster cried manfred heaven
directed my bloody hand to the heart of
my child the earth rocked and the clink
of more than mortal armor was heard
behind our doom is pronounced shall we
not can we not but dedicate the few
deplorable hours we have to live in
deprecating the farther wrath of heaven
you should have these written out so I
don't I truly don't know what to make of
these the alliteration amps up right as
the drama reaches its crisis so we might
think of something like what Garrett
Stewart sees as carefully knotted
linguistic and psychological threads and
Jane Eyre but murderous monster and
Manfred come from different voices and
I'm not sure that there's any necessary
relation between alliteration and
emotion in fact one might think that in
moments of intensity the mediating
material of text might seem to fall away
there is an onomatopoeia in the Clank of
Supernatural armor but this isn't
consistent either for how do breathy h's
fit stabbing or the drumbeat of Dee's a
pious resolution I haven't quite figured
out the logic of
but I'm tempted to think about these
alliterative birth in relationship to
the echo versus aggregation of Te a RS
or the anima in a grammatic play of
morolto relevant to is the argument
recurrent in prosody after Milton that
there is something distinctively gothic
about rhyme quote the invention of a
barbarous age and quote especially
insofar as it involves trivial play with
jingling words like the castle walls
crumbling behind man Fred words of
material and mortal fall infallible
emotion of O king and anyway all we got
when Walpole uses alliteration to
emphasize the letters of his words at
the novel's end might he again be
embracing the fact that words are made
of sounds embodied material phenomena
that combine disaggregate recombine
persist echoing one another Thanks
[Applause]
achieving stage of talks about how the
player who plays Macbeth with your
silently reversing it sees it many of
the things that you're describing it
seemed to be consequence of the thing
that for me this is a translation of
that quickly added I love the concept
detectives and I mean
that's great that's super useful and I
like the way then that the like the
character itself is being like the name
is the kind of material metonymy for
that and then it's picked up out of the
tech so there's something kind of like
portable and trinket II or something
about that I'll have to do more thinking
that's great John do you want to pick up
the other part of the question I mean I
believe in both and I don't I wouldn't
rule out the things from the 18th
century theater but I do think there's a
value added in the sound theorists
because the of notions like the psycho
acoustic contract and the acoustic usto
Sonic contract in which you get a
multiplication or magnification of the
effect by the presence of both now that
could happen in the theater as well but
I think also the methodical use of real
sounds in the Foley artist lab to make
effects that are either on the one hand
like those sounds in film or the use of
completely different objects to make
sounds that come become real probably we
can find analogs in theater but I think
it's much more vivid in in film theory I
don't see any harm I guess and I do see
value added but the historical dimension
from the 18th century theater would be
great as well of course Walpole was
involved in it and you know Marshall
brown rot writes about the effects of
the Gothic in plays prior
to Walpole so it's I don't doubt that
it's their follow-up question we're just
not a Trento base but just Foley Foley
based which I didn't know anything about
until today are those sound dubbers as
it were are they watching the film as
they do this they're not they're not
following a script no they're watching
they're watching I can see that yes I
mean there is such a there is sometimes
dub dialogue in films but but in general
the dialogue will have been recorded on
set there are many many instances where
sounds dubbed in most most obviously
singers and musicals
mentality is a kind of multiplication of
yeah kind of multiplicity or motive
multiplication whereas like for you
this idea of the border exerting its own
agency seems different from you know
that accountants it of the arabesque
against multiplicity right so I mean so
that was my sense of there being a kind
of different logic to each of your
accounts of something that on its face
might be so I'm just throwing that I
mean the arabesque isn't a term I've
thought a huge amount before before
writing this paper so I think what was
striking to me and in the
characterizations of it that I was
reading was that it was on the one hand
sort of picking up on that serpent up
the idea of the serpentine was
characteristic of characteristic of the
arabesque but there were also these that
the work the term shell work is used and
even other Kant doesn't talk use the
term arabesque but he talks about shell
work and describes formations that
people think are what could be described
as an arabesque but I don't I definitely
think I don't want to make the claim
that it's just it's one-dimensional or a
linear and not complex or I mean the
thing I was sort of struck by Moore was
that if you hear me say or minds about
thread and then yours is about weaving
and complexity it sounds like I'm
setting up a kind of opposition but I
don't really I don't want to do that and
I mean I'm getting the the language of
the thread and the shell I'm getting
from Hogarth where he is you know I'm
told many of you know he talks about the
threads as as I like it as the net the
shell is made up of a network of threads
you know it so it is a kind of complex
and he's not trying to kind of make it
into a
a binary opposition between two
completely distinct forms so I I think
there's room for both of those the
emphasis on bordering and on with
respect to the human body the very idea
of reduction say
[Music]
[Laughter]
right right right right right I do I
think I understand it's quite clear to
me that he's responding to a discourse
that emerges in the late 17th century
about the wolf elusive thing so that
turns up in its own way when he starts
thinking seriously about what it means
to do engraving it stops him the
question of the fact that engraving
looks like looks unfortunately like
texture mm-hmm but he also wants to get
to a sense of how is it that that lines
individual lines out of the surface
mm-hmm and that's that's the fun that's
one of the ways that that late 18th
century philosophy comes to the notion
of emergent properties so that's it I
mean that's what I see as being the as
with a root from the root from the
thread to show and Hogarth as he's
working you know yes there's a different
dimension that has to do and that has to
do with it was specifically the
serpentine it has to
returning to a body movement because
then you have a line to occupy space I
have a question for but I'm struck in
the context of the Gothic and a tronto
by the fact that Hogarth in the moment
that he wants to turn the shell into a
metaphor for this linear figure made of
threads his his phrasing is he says like
imagine a shell with its content scooped
out so nicely there's no talk to Sara
before about how I find this like this
phrase so gory evocative but the D
actually has to go through the motions
of imagining scooping out the material
organic contents of an actual biological
shell right that's creature inside in
order to turn it into a figure of just
of threads and and lines and anyway so
there's something there's there's a kind
of hunting right there's this kind of
gory and haunting and I know you have
another question but it just makes me
think that they would have had to scoop
out the helmet presumably but using it
as a because otherwise they would have
been but it always remains with right
yeah question I actually had a question
inspired by my Courtney's discussion of
echoes and I
want to bring Courtney's and and Wendy's
papers together I'm gonna try so I don't
know if you've already thought about
this but when you were describing it
when you're doing your reading of echoes
and particularly the echo verse where
with the echo is is like this is this
reiteration with a very minor formal
distortion that has an enormous
consequence in terms of the meaning
right or the significance of the of the
utterance it seemed to describe so
perfectly the epigraph to the Castle of
Otranto the hood the horror that needs a
little passage from Horus but I think
Shaun made reference to them in his
paper this morning
but where he he missed quotes Horus from
the ARS Poetica and it's a very very
minor tweak right like he alters the the
language in his really minor way but
completely reverses the meaning so so
the ARS Poetica and it says you know in
in the in the grotesque error the
ridiculous
the head and the foot cannot be
reconciled to you know their strange
fantasies with the head and foot cannot
be reconciled to a single forum and the
epigraph to Oh Toronto says strange
strange fantasies in which the head and
the foot are are nevertheless reconciled
to a single forum and this so this
reminded mute of Wendy's when it is
claimed that I completely agree with
that there's something about camp that
redeems like a heterosexual forms
there's something about that echo and
the distortion it performs that some had
like that that nevertheless gives a
former restores to inform it's like camp
distort is an echo right
of this like horrible original that
distorts it in such a way that it
actually provides a redeemed form for it
right like it gives it such like a form
of like a redeemed form to go forward
become better than D you might meant
like not want to kill yourself so but
but camp or or parody or whatever it is
as a kind of echo in the sense I guess
I'm just wondering if that's you know if
that's a if that's at all in a different
way of thinking about it or if that's or
if echo is just a term I not thought
about that I'm kind of making describe
things like camp you know and parody the
way we've always or we've been
describing them for a long time I mean
that's great the only thing I comes to
mind is the thing with the partial
because you take off the tee right or so
whereas I think camp is like the whole
shebang you know not the partial but you
know I think sort of fellow up question
that which was you know that the
alliterative stuff that you were reading
at the end there and your YouTube video
I mean they're both very camp and it
made me think about Pope's thing about
the Sodom esteem and echo to the sense
which I also have never understood
except that the most nominal level and
it made me wonder whether he's talking
about the effective and formal life of
camp actually which sort of explains why
it's the sound must seem and echoed in a
sense so I get what you're saying that
it's not partial it's beyond but it's
like more than not less than I would say
like in echo Versailles say like what
what do women most prized when we men
address like it ends with a dress like
what do and then what women most prized
is a space dress right or even just like
the ears and the ears comes back like
there I think there is a way I don't
know what you think about this but I
guess I would think that
um one of the things echo verse does is
just like throw attention on to like the
matter that's bringing it that's right
or like it brings attention to like the
medium in a certain way which like your
readings it exactly as well just kind of
like bring attention to like the the
rottenness of the words right um this is
like half thought but I was thinking
Sophie actually of your paper and the
like tension the contrast between like
belief and action yeah right like maybe
there's a way in which by just throwing
attention onto like the bodily onto the
medium on to like the the corporeal side
it just sort of like undercuts like
earnest belief like true spiritual you
know it's not like they really think in
those sort of overwrought terms but
there's a kind of awareness so John is
this really different than a foley
effect because on the one hand a foley
effect more real than real but it's not
a and and it's emphasizing like you know
the materiality and the key turning or
the foot stomping but to completely
masse I mean the effect is pure reality
in other words you're not our perception
of it yeah yes it's not camp fully
effect is not camp well no it's not if
it's effective because then it seems to
be part of a kind of natural world in
that clip it is the film yeah making a
medic right comment on itself I had a
question for you could I quickly go back
to Jesse's there was a medium other than
theater in the 18th century which is
phantasmagoria which really comes into
its own in the later part of the century
but there were sound effects in that as
well but Wendy I wonder is maybe I
missed something but it is do you
believe that Otranto was camp in 1764 or
is it only camp later
including now no what do you like it it
always had to be cam but but I I don't
know I mean I guess camp a lot of people
were scared to death by it you know this
is story about people going out in a
boat and reading it by candlelight was a
camp for Walpole what do you think the
answer to that is I mean this is yeah
well if you go back to Pope's if you go
back to the scribbler Ian Perry hoops
toast the artists sinking in poetry
which we were talking about you know and
I mean there's if not camp certainly a
send-up of the false already there in
whenever that was written in 17 20 or 18
or 21 or something like that by that
group of people so that that notion of a
send-up of the serious is certainly
already there and their mock panegyrics
and you know other other forms tale the
tub is brimming with them is that the
same as camp I'm just not sure I think
McCauley talking about Walpole's taste
in Antiquaries and not and but maybe
also the cost of the Toronto uses the
term the odd which I always thought was
a kind of good expression of you know
maybe that's not quite the camp and it's
not quite the novel but it's something
it's something a little off it's not
snarky you know I mean say more I mean I
campus really like it's only doing the
Donna Summer thing because like so it's
like weeping all the time it's like so
sad campus really sad and it's not just
choosing not to be sad about I don't
know
[Music]
yeah yeah right yeah yeah if you jump
off from Sontag then you know her ideas
I recall it from years ago is that
there's fundamentally always some other
reference there's a jump off in the camp
from something else and what's the
something else if it was camp in 1764
what's the something awesome I mean
patriarchy is I mean like it's the
script in which I mean the the overreach
of authority that's script you know or
the like or the meta novelistic script
of you know the peering into the
recesses of your heart script I mean I
dunno were you thinking I would follow
him he's quite explicit on the topic oh
say it's the fielding Richardson novel
yeah he's tired of it it doesn't have
enough in it he doesn't have fantasy in
it you know that's what's being set up I
think whether you call it camp or not
it's that that kind of high novel that
we so adore is what he's sending up he
says it right in the previs but you make
this brilliant point Jon that that has
been so influential to me that the
Richard Sounion novel is always setting
itself up you know like it's it's always
self exposed committed to a kind of self
exposure yeah which is why a lot of
people don't like it
yeah yeah yeah that seems right to me I
was I was thinking when you were talking
Wendy that like in some ways I feel like
I was saying because I mean you were
quoting some notes for nose on wonder as
the concept of anything when the mind
comes to a stand it's like oh god I was
just like making the same argument over
again cuz I was kind of saying that the
book makes the mind come to a stand but
I don't think I want to call it wonder
or that's not yeah not trying to say
that again but it's it's it's it's the
effect of that indeterminacy or kind of
code switching where you know are you
experiencing this as a suspenseful novel
or are you immersed in it or is somebody
and then other characters in the novel
following Clues or are they just
experiencing these weird dream states
and hallucinations and not knowing what
to do with them
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I was thinking
more about how the preface is have it I
mean I know I'm just like seeing shells
everywhere now but they're just that the
fact that there are these these frames
that there are these frameworks that
almost overwhelmed the text itself and
as Margaret Duty's argued perhaps with
excessive vigor that romance was still
very much in print and alive
at this time so that switching is not
between a hypothetical form that's old
and a new form is they're both they're
[Music]
trying to figure out what actually comes
out of the frame in that it isn't in the
portrait is by the portrait I mean the
thing on the canvas I think it's
actually supposed to be the figure
that's the only thing that can shake its
head yeah okay so I just want to say
that and so that you know we know what
we're talking about and similarly with
the cheek of the
the cheek of the helmet as your sort of
emblem Sara for this metaphor because
that's actually a baton II right it's
the cheek the cheek is the helmet has
the cheek only to the extent that that
comet is designed to point to the human
body that it no longer contains right so
so those are two things like to like you
know material and then I wanted to point
to something that intrigued me about the
Foley video which is that there's an
interesting there there's a kind of
interestingly naive literalism where in
order to produce the sound they seem to
feel they have to move their bodies in
the same way so we went to the moment or
in order to make the sound of falling
down whereas presumably you could make a
you know it sound like that this video
just happened to be the most vivid I
could find but but also I had two
minutes long and I I had to cut it off
before the leg of lamb this is a
technical problem in the making of film
I mean in theory though all those Falls
and so forth when they were shot could
have been recorded on the soundtrack
with the dialogue but it doesn't work
because there's so much other noise
around and and so with certain Foley
things there has to be a literal Ennis
that the click of the latch now they
could go to a lot more work and click
the latch some other way and in fact now
much of that is digital anyway I mean
the real Foley is this kind of
physicality but no I think it's to me
literally literal but you would if you
just had the video of the two guys and
all of their stuff you know assuming you
would have sent the idea that the chase
in the film creates a certain suspense
you would not experience that watching
these guys hammer on trash cans and fall
over and go did you notice how the one
guy went running down the hall went and
so so yes exactly that's right you know
so I think your points well-taken in in
some ways but the I guess it was for a
longer paper I would go more into
parallel technical issues in the novel
about about how these effects become
real I used this blanket term about the
audiovisual contract to kind of cover a
lot of that it's you know so just jump
thinking you're you say years in the
wishin Y is a problem with materiality
being solved with materiality which
isn't good ya know something is that I
mean I guess I just wanted to know does
it does it matter for us to get clear on
what what emerges from the frame yeah
and it's still magnetic as partly what
you're saying is an app that like both
in the the Foley and the cheeks that
these these are not just objects or
artificial effects but they're still
kind of bound to the body in some way
whether it's like representational II in
the figure of the portrait or like the
cheeks because they're molded on the
cheeks and I think that's really true
and I just wanted to say I think you're
totally right that I don't want it to
flatten it out all into will
everything's indeterminate and then at
the end that seems boring and not true
but but yeah I think I think we need to
cling to the specificity of these these
particular moments and I wouldn't need
to think harder about like exactly how
they work and in the pepper panel and
the and the cheek of the Cask part of us
coming out of the frame is Walpole with
the second preface his authorship also
apparently it's thinking of a particular
portrait at Strawberry Hill because he
mentions that too in a letter he says
when that happens that you should think
of I don't remember what the portrait is
so that would be interesting to know
like what specific images know what is
it what is being imitated here I mean to
me this book is like sci-fi you know
it's it's using the techniques that
we're familiar with from the realist
novel realist novel but what's being
imitated isn't there and this is part of
the critique of the so call of the
feeling Richardson novel that's not
there either
you know but he's calling attention to
the not their nests of the objects being
represented you know it's it's a it's
it's a it's I think a brilliant treatise
on mimesis you know which is part of
what I'm trying to get at with the with
the Foley effects so they're just dumb
per se and I mean the Richardson feeling
thing kind of is there in the sense that
if you sort of strip away all that
kind of medieval stuff it's basically
just a family having a row about his
term has expanded fantasy there's not
enough fantasy yep
the agility of this world the
publication's in the book preface and
tries to treat this as an historical
novel to make it work
the reason I'm hesitating is that I am
interested in something that I haven't
fully thought through it but B I think
is a little subtle which is for me which
is you know the obvious move to make
about the Gothic and all this kind of
stuff and fantasy and and everything is
to say you know there's just to be
really similar there's way too much
empirical stuff going on there's way too
much real there's way too much material
there's way too much stuff that's
supposed to be like the thing it's
imitating so we should jump either way
and we should reinstate belief we should
we should prioritize belief over
knowledge we should we should prioritize
credulity over skepticism bla bla bla
and what seems aren't interesting to me
about that solution is that it isn't
true
and it doesn't work
[Laughter]
[Music]
and you know that is sort of where I
fall off the edge of the world I don't
really have that much more to say about
that because they haven't thought
through but I think that that the Gothic
isn't proposing a return to the
credulous and the superstitious or the
immaterial or the non real the counter
empirical as a sort of curative or
antidote to the real I don't think even
though it makes that gesture it feels to
me and you know I've never thought about
camp before so I'm very very beginner
mind about it but it feels interesting
to me in sort of the relation of belief
to knowledge or of credulity to
skepticism feels similar to me in the
Gothic as the relation of camp to
heterosexual matrimony
it is a solution that does all the
things that you said no matter but I
yeah I mean I have to think more about
it but but the the note I would like to
sound is that it isn't I'm I'm trying to
think through the and this is where all
the stuff about involuntary obligation
or what was the other thing I talked
about like but anyway that's where all
that all comes in because I'm sort of
trying to think through this idea or
basically I'm just trying to think
through the idea that we don't have to
sort of continue to chew on the kind of
remnants of of credulity versus Kris
skepticism and belief versus knowledge
and all that stuff and yet we're dealing
you know what this here's the archive
right right right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I'm actually on that point I
would say that Coleridge is in fact
putting his it's not like Coleridge
thinks up the willing suspension of
disbelief per se but he puts his finger
or he identifies something that seems to
me he gives it a name but it doesn't
seem to me that that's the origin moment
for that particular intellectual or
cognitive that's all we think those
words fancy fit into this belief
skepticism that's a depression so how
does he use the word fancy he does
precisely his work oh yeah I can
invention has not been wanting but the
great resources of fancy have been
dammed up by a strict adherence to
common life hmm that's a really good
question I don't know I mean I bet I bet
I could give you a good answer that but
I definitely well it's a moan it's a
continuing battle against Catholicism
yeah in the Anglican Church yeah I mean
I think there are a lot of phantasms of
fancy out there yeah yeah well I mean I
guess part of what I was trying to say
about his dad
is that he you know he was all he was
sort of pretty invested in in in making
fancy more safe or something by sort of
limiting its its impact hardly the guy
Hogarth painted yes shall we continue
the conversation and formally and thank
all the panelists today and this morning
Vince afternoon is 24 wonderful